il n'abuse jamais des scratchs l'idée
vocoder doudou basse et gwendal offre
une musique électro d'une grande
richesse leur groupe s'appelle sapiens
sapiens
dans l'esprit des fameux d'eau de
l'électro tel daft punk ou les beastie
boys les tourangeaux peuvent désormais
compter sur sapiens sapiens mais
pourquoi ce nom les gars
ça fait un petit rapprochement entre
l'homme évoluer la musique évolué et
puis on est sur une musique un peu
vintage aussi avec des vieux instruments
et c'est néandertal quand même comme
état d'esprit de l'électro sainte et
festif avec des sons bizarres
une atmosphère parfois intimiste
aérienne mais sur laquelle on bouge
toujours
quand j'écris un morceau je le fais un
petit peu pour en l'imaginant sur scène
est ce que ça va pulser est ce que dans
quoi je vais amener les gens et le cet
effet un petit peu de cette façon pour
faire voyager les gens vers du rythme et
puis après les faire redescendre et puis
les faire danser au maximum
d'ailleurs les programmateurs de terres
du son les cautionnent ces fameux coups
de coeur on sait 4 à 5 vous qu'on
soutient parents tout au long de l'année
dans un trail de résidence
d'accompagnement et des dallas
communication et pour un concert final
sur sur le festival terres du son
sapiens sapiens devrait sortir un album
en septembre prochain
lui aussi fait partie de la troupe l'apd
est bonne
comme vous le savez montauban participe
pour autres et atlandes l'été nous avons
un rameur qui nous a fait faux bond si
je peux me permettre l'expression
le petit nouveau christ y en a qui on
souhaite la bienvenue bienvenue
christian
femme a tué demandé de le suivre au
commissariat
un concert gratuit
le saxophoniste thomas de pourquery
jouera ce soir à orléans
proche du cubisme auguste herbin
supprime la notion de perspective quant
au module décimaux n'est il s'inspire
directement de l'alphabet un peu comme
un jeu d'enfant
et l'on referme cet agenda avec txiki
route
joe jackson
qui sera demain soir à château la
vallière